speaking of great talents you've worked
with so many of them if you go to your
website you have a long list of people
that you've worked with
in what capacity were you working with
those individuals
like james franco
penelope cruz different things like that
yes i've worked as a coach
i've coached the different actors and
very well-known actors on different
projects on broadway on movie roles on
television series me a slew of different
things and also as a director uh i've
worked with some
pretty amazing talent you know jason
sit again norman reedus just now yes i
have a norman reedus in this movie that
is just out to hello herman
jason alexander issa morales ron perlman
and i have just a list of amazing actors
that i've had
the absolute um you know i've had the
luck and the honor to work with
and
in what capacity are you working with
them is it for a role and you're on set
and you're
in terms of coaching well it varies
an actor will come to me whether they
have booked the role and maybe it's
something that's challenging a character
that's a stretch
or something that scares them you know
in terms of of the story
or um
a role that they're trying to get that
they're screen testing for that they're
auditioning for
and so actors come to me in different
different capacities you know and how is
it for you to work with someone that's
done so many roles versus maybe someone
that's never even been to school for
acting is your approach different in
some sense i would imagine it would be
it is of course it's different if i'm
working with somebody that you know even
has not worked a lot but let's say
they're a young star from the disney
channel
or if i'm working with you know somebody
that won an oscar
um
absolutely you know you intuitively work
with people depending on who they are
and
you know their body of work and um and
also what you're talking about what's
the project what what help do they need
i mean i think to be an acting coach
is to say well how can i help you